thanks to brilliant for sponsoring a
section of this video today we take it
for granted that we can predict what the
weather will do a week or so from now
but for most of human history the idea
that weather could be predicted was
frankly
ludicrous yes there was some folk wisdom
for example if you saw a field of cows
that was lying down that meant that rain
was
possibly on the way and in the uk
specifically if you saw
a red sky in the morning that meant that
bad weather was probably on the way and
there is actually
some truth to that one as late as 1854
a member of parliament suggested that
perhaps with modern science
that the weather in london could be
predicted a day ahead of it actually
happening and
he was literally laughed out of the
houses of parliament
whether it could be assessed and maybe
even understood it was believed
but not predicted weather couldn't be
predicted and if anybody said that they
could predict the future like that
well they were unnatural they were a
witch
various laws in england in the tudor and
stuart periods
so the 16th and 17th centuries
specifically targeted witches and
sorcery
and made a variety of activities
punishable by death
one of which was very specifically the
ability to predict the future
for some reason predicting where things
that you have lost will be
in the future was very witchy in
particular
eventually however it was realized that
these witchcraft laws were basically
being used to justify the mob murder of
harmless old women and so in 1735 the
then
british parliament passed the witchcraft
act of 1735
which repealed that previous witchcraft
legislation and instead
imposed fines and imprisonment on
anybody who claimed to be able to
practice
witchcraft so in the eyes of the law it
was no longer illegal to be a witch or a
wizard because parliament
seemingly didn't really believe in those
things anymore but it was illegal to
pretend to be able to
do witchery or sorcery such as
i don't know pretending to be able to
predict the future
fast forward now to the 19th century a
lot of technological innovation happened
between
the 18th and 19th centuries but the most
relevant to our story here is the
development of communication
technologies
specifically the development of the
electric telegraph
being a primitive form of electronic
communication the telegraph allowed for
pretty much
instantaneous communication of
information over
vast distances for the first time in
human history
information across an entire country in
fact even an entire continent
could be collated into a central data
set
in pretty much real time that meant that
observations of the weather in
particular
could be compiled in a way that just
couldn't before
even with the fastest communication
possible by the time a weather report
from say
aberdeen reached london the weather in
aberdeen would have moved on
completely making the weather report
useless and here enters into our story
a guy called robert fitzroy who are you
who are so wise in the ways of science
you may already be familiar with robert
fitzroy as the man who captained hms
beagle on its round-the-world trip
carrying a certain charles darwin
but that's not even half of fitzroy's
contributions to science
following the ludicrous suggestion in
the british parliament that the weather
in london could be
predicted that same year 1854
fitzroy founded the uk meteorological
office
fitzroy's met office received electric
telegraphs from observers
all over the country making use of a
newly established network of observers
that were scattered
far and wide they took their telegrams
and compiled what we call a synoptic
chart this is basically a picture of
what the atmosphere is doing over a wide
area
it's a snapshot in time of how the
atmosphere is
behaving and the uk met office was
originally founded purely to
collect this information and store it
away nothing else
fitzroy though realized that certain
features of these charts repeated
themselves
and that if he were to compile a
sequence of synoptic charts that he
could maybe predict what a
future chart in that sequence might look
like qualitatively at least
so in 1861 fitzroy started publishing
storm warnings based on these predicted
synoptic charts
basically telling shipping fleets
whether it was safe to go out to sea or
if they should come back to harbour
later that same year he did what many
people thought was impossible
he produced the world's first weather
forecast
he actually invented the term forecast
published in the times of london
on august 1 1861. this was the start of
regular weather prediction as we know it
today government scientists poring over
data that's been collected and compiled
into synoptic charts
and predicting what the weather's going
to do next gazing
into the future
wait the witchcraft act of 1735 was
still in effect
and from this point onwards in the eyes
of the law the uk met office was now a
house
of witchcraft and wizardry but surely
the uk government would pick up
on this and change the part of the law
where it said you can't see into the
future when they realized they were
harboring a bunch of wizards out back
nope the witchcraft act of 1735
stayed law until 1951
where it was superseded by something
called the fraudulent mediums act and
then some eu legislation
the last person to be imprisoned
under the witchcraft act of 1735 was a
woman called helen duncan
in 1944 that means that
for nearly a century in the eyes of the
law
the uk government was using sanctioned
wizards
to produce weather forecasts
[Applause]
now you could look at this and laugh at
how silly people used to be believing
that only witches and wizards could see
into the future
but to me at least this is an
interesting example of how
technology changes our perceptions of
our surroundings
the only reason we consider whether to
be predictable
in any meaningful way is because the
development of information sharing
technologies like the electric
telegraph without information gathered
over
a large area in pretty much real time
it may as well be sorcery to say that
you can predict
what the weather's going to do next it
just so happened that the development of
the law
didn't quite match the development of
the technology
oh thank goodness we left that behind in
the past
how do you sustain a business model in
which users don't pay for your service
senator we run ads
i see much of the history of science is
really a history of
technology you can keep up to date and
avoid becoming history yourself
by picking up some new skills on
brilliant brilliant is a website and app
built on the principle that you learn
best when getting your hands dirty
doing and solving problems in real time
crucially brilliant isn't about
memorizing facts or lengthy
formula it's about the skills that you
acquire by just
getting your hands in and doing and if
you do make a mistake while doing one of
these problems
no problem brilliant emphasizes making
mistakes in learning is a really
powerful
learning experience and those mistakes
don't matter whether you want to start
at the basics of maths and science or
dive into cutting-edge topics like
cryptocurrency or neural networks they
have something for everybody i've
personally used brilliant to brush up on
my quantum mechanics and my chemistry
and i'm going to be checking out their
course on machine
learning for an upcoming video project
to get access to all this
and more for yourself or for somebody
else in your life then head to
brilliant.org
simon clark and join a community of 8
million
learners and if you're one of the first
200 people to use the link in the
description you'll get a sweet 20
off a premium annual subscription too
thank you so much to brilliant for being
such a long-term supporter of this
channel and for sponsoring
this video if you found this story of
wizard weatherman interesting then you
are going to absolutely
love my book firmament the hidden
science of weather climate change in the
air that surrounds us
available for pre-order right now link
down there in the below
coming out in january thank you very
much for watching this video all the way
to the end i really hope that you
enjoyed this story which was a little
nugget of information i uncovered whilst
i was researching the book if you did
enjoy the video then let me know down in
the comments
also let me know if there are any other
little weird stories like this in the
history of science that you know and
perhaps
i don't because i love this stuff you
can also pop this video a like share the
video with people you think might enjoy
it and if you're not already then
you can subscribe to the channel if
you'd like to see more stuff like this
thank you again for watching
and i'll see you in the next one